what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Dan Donny is the CEO
of securin see a financial markets
infrastructure technology company
focused on enhancing capital formation
and stimulating global liquidity in this
conversation we discussed Dan's time
working as the chief innovation officer
of the Defense Intelligence Agency how
innovation works in the CIA and NSA why
a focus on innovation inside large
organizations is important what he is
building with saccharin see and why
capital formation and global liquidity
is important to improve via blockchain I
really enjoyed this conversation guys
bang bang I'm here with Dan we got a
whole bunch of stuff to cover I'm super
excited about this because you've got a
very different past I think than most
people who come on the show in the
defense world intelligence world and
then now you're working on tokenization
and compliance tools so a whole gamut of
things but I think so much for coming
and doing this thanks Paul really good
fortune we're recording this on a nice
cold day in New York City so we're warm
now inside and I forgot my jacket of all
things through the streets out there
it's uh yeah it's cold but it could be
worse right let's start from the very
beginning where where'd you grow up and
kind of how did you get into the defense
and intelligence stuff so I'm a farm boy
from western Pennsylvania okay well mark
near Pittsburgh south Greensburg okay I
don't know guys country when I when I
got deployed to Iraq I was there with a
bunch of guys in western Pennsylvania
but more like Brookville and all that
stuff yeah linzer's for the folks at
home who we don't even need to go into
that so I I started coding as a 10 year
old built cattle auction programs as a
teenager went off didn't really frankly
know a whole lot about what was going on
in the world as I was in a closed-in
backwoods tiny town Turkey towns
actually the name of my hometown Turkey
town turkey town Pennsylvania we got
only a Pennsylvania yeah more
cows than people I my older brother went
off to the Naval Academy and I saw him
come back from from there a different
man and positive or negative Oh
completely positive I mean he left as a
boy came back as a man and that made an
impression on me so that was a path I
chose went into the Naval Academy was
fortunate enough to go to MIT for grad
school straight out and spent several
years on a sub a couple years teaching
at the academy and then got out in 2000
just before 9/11 got it and when you got
out what was the thought process of what
you want to do sorry having kids so I
actually went to work for startup this
is a very formative for me the name of
the company was virtual logic and it was
built around a concept of a virtual
company where you have a shell at the
top of just administrative systems
things that you need to to function as
an employee but underneath that was a
bunch of entrepreneurs and so they were
really creating conditions where you
would go and and eat your own and so as
you came into this you're really being
mentored by entrepreneurs in the DC area
is one of the fastest growing companies
in in DC purchased by a big company I
won't say who and they completely
obliterated the entrepreneurial spirit
and a number of us decided to leave
leave 9/11 hit I had been doing AI
research starting my grad thesis was AI
control of the nuclear reactor at MIT so
I've been working in AI was recruited to
NSA and worked there for almost a decade
in artificial intelligence so we got to
talk about nuclear reactors because I
had a mark Schneider come on the podcast
who spent 20 years in the Navy and
worked in a number of the nuclear energy
and kind of power aspects of the Navy
and I was shocked at just how obvious it
is that nuclear power is important right
in and kind of that I understand there's
much a controversy around it to some
degree but what is AI controlled nuclear
power yeah so obviously safety is a huge
and so mechanisms to allow you to detect
when things are going wrong all right
a is a really great tool even in the
early 90s to be able to pick up early
signs of problems that are coming and
this is things like there's problems
within the facility or there's problems
external to the facility that may start
to inhibit what we're trying to do at
the facility really all the above but
specifically in this case detecting
anomalies in the reactor problems with
pumps among other things early signs of
boiling among other things that
shouldn't happen and so having effective
tools to combine all the information to
be able to make a decision faster
obviously is important got it the irony
you know I people seen the movie
Chernobyl the that's even in in the
early 90s the kinds of technologies that
were being produced for for a nuclear
energy of self safe reactors that could
not even if someone was malicious
explode cause damage were produced yeah
you just couldn't get him to market
because there was so much fear around
the industry so the irony is the
reactors that stayed around
we're ones that we're using older
technologies that weren't better yeah
and and obviously the way the Russians
built their reactors was not safe yeah
it's just fascinating to me my favorite
part of the conversation with Mark was
that they put the rods in a pool it just
sits in the pool for 10 years I was like
man this is like a homemade you know
science experiment that actually works
right but but but it was very clear I
think just the the complexity right
involved in this and it becomes very
obvious that machines are probably going
to be better at doing it I would have
thought in the future but it sounds like
even in the 90s the machines were
actually better at it than than humans
well so it's it's one thing to do a
research thesis at MIT it's another
thing to have it in a production reactor
yeah for sure so alright so you go you
join the NSA first then you spend time
at Department of Homeland Security and
then you spend time at the Defense
Intelligence Agency so for those at home
I'm gonna use acronyms so NSA is the
Nash
Security Agency DHS is the Department of
Homeland Security and then dia is the
department of intelligence agency I feel
like I've got my alphabet soup down for
the day what you do at the NSA I was
part of what was originally known as our
de the advanced research development
activity there okay it later became AI
ARPA as it merged with CIA's research on
and so I spent that decade in in our da
and then I ARPA okay my focus was AI so
I was there the early programs one
called novel intelligence for massive
data another one that I worked with was
a quaint advanced question-answering for
intelligence okay so those programs were
acquaint for example was about teaching
machines to answer questions and the
intent was interesting analytic
questions I worked with the founders of
IBM's Watson capability so the the
capabilities that competed on Jeopardy
actually started in that early work in
the early 2000 so you guys are looking
at this as we think that this is
possible so let's go find today's
technologies and try to build the the
capabilities to ask a machine a question
have an answer etc or are you kind of
reverse engineering or kind of how does
that work Rex I think the defense
organizations and kind of community has
done a great job of driving research and
development over the years and then
commercializing the technology how does
that kind of come together as you're
there working on it yeah so in advanced
research activities you're really
looking at the time horizon 10 20 years
out ok so again at the time working
quantum computing among other things and
the the roots of AI and specifically the
focus there was on natural language
processing and really building the
foundation and why does the intelligence
community care what is DoD care
it's about decision advantage so the the
impacts of failed intelligence decisions
are obvious 9/11 was was failed
intelligence so we need decision
advantage we need it on the battlefield
so throughout history battles are won
based on decision
advantage so the question is how can you
get better information than the
adversary I couldn't make decisions
faster and better than the adversary and
that involves processing information
faster in in finance it's known as alpha
and so it's the same basic mechanisms so
our our focus first is how can you
process a large amount of pros in order
to help an an elective Lee a Bionic
knowledge worker allowing a person to
reach out further into the information
space and my specific focus was on how
do you blend human intuition and machine
speed in the space and we did a lot of
work there so one of things that I want
to clarify because I feel really
strongly about a part of this work and
then the other part I think is less
controversial there's the front end of
like what data do we have right which is
all the collection surveillance and all
that kind of stuff and I think I don't
want to have that conversation today
because I think that part of the
conversation one is controversial too
it's a really really nuanced
conversation that would take hours for
us to go through what I really want to
focus on is kind of where you had an
expertise and a lot of experience which
is there's data that's provided to you
right and it's how do we analyze the
data that we have regardless of whether
we should have it not have it is it's
from citizens militaries you know
adversaries whatever you're really
focused on ok we have this data how do
we look at this data and analyze it for
insights and then also to make decisions
from it but that's a pretty wide open
kind of you know white space like like
how do you start to to look at that and
say this is the areas we want to focus
on or start building it yeah well look
the fundamental challenge is this so
search engines that people know are
really about how does a person find the
information that they need well in a
massive amount of data it's actually the
opposite question that's important how
does the data find the person who needs
it so that comes down to valuing
information obviously there's a massive
amount of information what do I need to
know right now and the metrics for the
at the very end of my research one of
the things that we discovered that was
profound
still profound is that valuing
information matters
- - folks it's relative so a piece of
information that's relative to me and
what I do is different so there's no
universal sense of value but it came
down to four fundamental parameters or
dimensions obviously relevance matters
things that are relevant to you
different than me and if I'm getting a
bunch of information not relevant to you
that's that's not useful but it's
profoundly important to get novel data
that is data that you haven't you
something you didn't know before okay
well here's what was profound about that
search engines Google's PageRank
algorithm others really drive popularity
popularity and novelty are almost the
inverse of each other
so in other words if you're a knowledge
and expert in a field getting a feed of
what's popular for folks is actually
giving you stuff you already know that's
not useful so the very algorithms that
drive more towards sensuality and are
not useful in terms of delivering
valuable information you need novelty
and mathematically it's a much harder
problem and novelty meaning so if you
take that search algorithm the things
that show up on the first page or the
most popular pieces of information it's
the most discovered kind of the most
widely accepted as fact or truth et
cetera novelty would be what's the thing
on the four hundred and seventy second
page of the Google search results so
it's related it's just either not very
well integrated into that that kind of
web of information on the first page or
also hasn't been as discovered or as
popular etc is that yes all right
mathematically what's hard about it is
exactly that so novelty is what is not
known okay
and so by almost by the essence of it
it's if you were just to use an
information theoretic approach and put
your finger right in the center of what
facts about something those will be than
what is well known you so the important
and hard problem is how you get to what
is new not close to the center but
related to the center and so there's
some hard challenges associated with
doing that by the way search engines
don't do this well yes and actually
they're built to do the opposite right
like that they they don't want to
surface the novel information at the
forefront of the results because that is
unlikely to be what
the majority of people are looking for
that's right so this opened up an
interesting line of research but then I
was off to DHS to do other things of how
do you actually just get valuable things
that you don't know that you need so
what was the work there
DHS I went to work in the enterprise
service delivery office and I've been a
coder and really an algorithm developer
since early on and since I was a kid
there I learned to develop Enterprise
Systems okay and the DHS was made up
post 9-11 of 14 different components
that came together that's a train wreck
if you ever had government agencies
tried to work together or components
especially when they're brought together
it's it's hard to work in that setting
and creating systems that could work in
a coalition environment where people are
different Authority competing interests
is a hard challenge mm-hmm it turns out
to be central to the financial system so
I really learned some key skills there I
happen to work on a very important
project that led to some of the things
that we did later okay um what was that
project called self check so I was the
lead architect on on the system it was a
threat to Eve Arif I so many people know
he verified some mechanism to determine
if one's eligible to work here in the
states it was full of errors and the
government had spent a lot and what that
means on the ground if it's if it's
giving the wrong information as someone
who's actually eligible to work is not
able to work that's a problem and so
Congress knew it they spent a lot of
money trying to fix it and the team came
up with a novel approach to go after
this which is let people check their own
government held privacy data now and
make sure it's right and if there's an
error then allow the person to raise a
flag and then the government to go about
fixing it what that requires is if I'm
going to check what the government knows
about me from a privacy perspective it
better be me who's checking on my data
and you you know I shouldn't be able to
see yours and vice versa
so that came down to identity proofing
who how do you know that someone is who
they say they are and that piece when we
combine that on this back-end engine of
e-verify we created a system that is
very effective
what were the ways that you could verify
so first
yeah but what do you know other
biometrics other components now
oftentimes the very people we were
trying to verify or folks who weren't
here in the States for long so they're
here or something right
so you may not have a whole lot of data
but you can look your records ask
questions
the mechanisms that you detect you get
to a high level of certainty that they
are who they say their have continued to
evolve even since since that time get it
but but there's a lot of tools now and
there's a lot of players in the
financial services space who have worked
on or are working on effective identity
proofing models but it's important
problem for the financial services space
in general and the problem we find
fascinating now is not just can we
verify you are who you say you are but
how do we verify that you're permitted
to perform a function yeah yeah for sure
and so you spent time at DHS did how
much would work there you guys won some
awards and things like that but then you
ended up at the DIA and the DIA is it's
fascinating to me because most people
know of the CIA
all right the Central Intelligence
Agency the Defense Intelligence Agency
is much less known but equally as cool
in my opinion
so kind of one just give us a
description of what the DIA is and then
kind of someone working it there yeah
Hollywood doesn't favor dia if you've
seen the movie American sniper yeah
they're actually mentioned in there but
yeah so the Defense Intelligence Agency
has a specific mission of serving the
warfighter so the central intelligence
agencies for really national security
but it's important that the someone
who's out in the field is getting the
information they need to I was sort of
as CIA is more diplomatic and kind of
quote unquote spy and you know all that
kind of stuff where the dia is much more
ingrained in the military and those
soldiers airmen etc that's right so it's
a different delivery target you're
actually trying to get your information
to folks out at the different customer
so it in the in performing that mission
there I really got it my role was chief
innovation officer so to be clear I
don't have the cold stories that some
folks have you know
when they're up but you have really out
there in the edge mine was really how
does an agency a government agency get
the best things that emerge into the
hands of the people who need it and this
is a fascinating challenges it's
actually a really critical challenge for
banks because banks were really
struggling with this right now they know
they need to reform how do they get the
best stuff and oftentimes in in
government settings
folks think Advanced Research is the
answer you know that's where the kind of
community that I came from we go figure
out a heart problem we'll go and solve
it it's almost the wrong approach to
innovation so who's gonna break down two
problems I used to joke if you think R&D
and innovation are the same thing
you don't do either one well R&D is
about knowing that there's a hard
problem and going really breaking down
that hard problem really over years like
building a quantum computer and then
solving that hard problem innovation is
you don't know the problem but there's a
lot of cool solutions out there great
things are happening in Silicon Valley
how do we get to use those that's very
much there's a great quote from Joey
Ito's really one of the fathers of
innovation if you want to be innovative
lower the cost of failure so that's
fundamentally yet R&D programs by their
structure their long-term big plans
they're expensive internal blockchain
R&D efforts at a bank can be quite
expensive
the real answer is to as quickly as
possible try the new things that are
emerging outside and building the
techniques that allow you to quickly
sift through those and deliver them into
mission settings that requires an
integration framework so what you'll see
about our technology approach is we've
made blockchain very easy to integrate
into enterprises so banks can get access
to the great technologies part of you
know you got some great cool night
vision technology developed somewhere
maybe even overseas how do you get it in
the hands of the warfighter when it has
to interact with all of the other
systems that they work with well it's
it's important to have quick integration
frameworks to make that possible and
these were the kinds of challenges I
honed my skills there got it into
some of the things that you guys worked
on while at DIA because there we were
talking beforehand some of them I
expected and some of them I did not
expect yeah look so the emergence of
quantum computing that as it became
practical that cyber attack defense
techniques just cool technologies across
the board mostly about information
processing and this cool technology
called blockchain you know this was
obviously of interest and I'll tell you
the the interest in 2012 was tracing
what was happening in the blockchain
space so this is crazy because you are
not the first to tell me either
on the podcast or off kind of after
recordings of somebody who worked in the
defense law enforcement regulation you
know sectors that 2012 is actually the
year multiple times that has been
mentioned where government agencies
realized this is real we need to pay
attention and started working on some
aspect of Bitcoin blockchain etc for you
guys it sounds like you guys were in
2012 already realizing hey there's
transactions occurring here there's this
immutable ledger we don't actually
understand who these people are that are
transacting how do we take the identity
work and overlay it with transactions
and start figuring this out right what
was the the goal or why did you guys
think that was important to work to
focus on well I'll tell you so I'll give
you exactly the moment so I did my first
Bitcoin transaction I was out the Aspen
Institute's I'm getting really cool and
you know then our interest was chain
analysis and so it's really in figuring
out the intent behind a transaction why
did someone just move this money and so
you look across it and patterns just
stick out immediately as to what they
are and whenever you see this pattern
you see ransomware when you see that
pattern you see trafficking or
laundering etc sticks out so there you
know obviously that matters and so then
the intelligence PD doesn't care about
who Satoshi is it doesn't care it does
care about you know when the North
Koreans are using it to to attack
our private sector components and then
laundering the money out so they care
about that and attack an attack in that
situation is they're busy hacking Sony
hack but others you know so they break
into people's wallets remind me what
happened with the Sony hack , so let's
see what the time for him was it's
probably 2015 2016 the North Koreans
came after Sony Sony put out a movie
that made fun of the North Korean leader
and so poking the bear there and
basically broke into all Sony systems
and then took their intellectual
property their private emails split all
over the place and busy trying to
embarrass Sony embarrassin and they did
but not only embarrassed them but
tactically hurt them their movie scripts
all of the things that were coming out
suddenly splayed out there on the
internet so they they successfully
carried out a cyberattack there now they
do other things as well they you know
there's many folks I'm sure probably in
space who are attacked I've had folks
come after me um nation-states who do in
this space so you know it's a distinct
threat they steal they launder but the
thing that really made it apparent to me
that there was an important need to
regulate and and this industry was when
you saw the nexus between Bitcoin
transactions at the time and human
trafficking so you could see the
linkages in terms of how these things
are being used to move human beings and
bottom line you no matter how you come
down on this in terms of the community
is government's to have a responsibility
to protect their people this is a thing
that societies cannot accept so the need
to intervene you know is there's many
anonymity advocates for anonymity you
can't have it anytime you have anonymous
transit you can have private
transactions and we work our tail off
for privacy but anonymity is not we
can't stand in a setting like this
because all through human history when
you've allowed for an anonymous
financial transactions what follows is
untoward the kind of things that
governments have to step in so two
questions one
cassia's anonymous transactions for the
most part how does the defense sector
kind of go to sleep at night okay with
physical cash versus anything that's you
know using a keyboard well look so first
lots more bad things happen with the US
dollar than with Bitcoin so you know
Epirus in this but so if I give you $20
right now people would know because
they're watching but if we did it out on
the streets no one would know that I
just did that so you're right I can do
an anonymous transaction with cash I can
move I can give you $100
give you a million dollars and you'll
see that leave the bank and someone's
gonna say where'd that go as part of
this but what I can't do practically is
carry a million dollars worth of cash to
Iran no it can be done to be sure but
there are laws against moving more than
ten thousand you must report when you
move more than ten thousand dollars
across borders it can be seized
so there's significant risks associated
with it it's precisely for this region
so cash can't move anonymously anywhere
in the world efficiently and yes so but
breaking that down I think it's
important you can do it it's just much
more difficult because when you got to
carry the physical cash to there's a
bunch of checks that are kind of invoked
and it literally involves the physical
movement of things right with less
people planes you can't do it legally
without government oversight and if you
do it illegally there's risk
I can send ten million dollars a hundred
million dollars a Bitcoin if I had it
that was she did you know to someone in
Iran and within a few minutes they could
could use it and so that's the point or
I could send it to a human trafficker in
in Thailand and that that's the thing
where a government has to care about
that they have to care so this is a big
thing with stable coins that we are
intent on doing regulated stable coins
and we have the tools to do regulates
data points there's this feeling sort of
in the industry well it's a managed
stable coin that should be enough in
other words can go wherever it wants to
go and it's only when it crosses into
the financial sector
it matters that's not true that's it
can't be true I mean it it is true now
only because it's happening at small
scales but FinCEN's already said you
know look at a certain scale we're
stepping in here and so how how do you
think about the trade-off between the
privacy and kind of the individual
rights versus what I'll describe it from
the extreme more as a mental exercise
but like the surveillance state right
hey the the man the government is
watching and preventing me from doing
things etc versus I have privacy and my
individual rights that are you know kind
of inherent in the American democracy
yeah so privacy is a fundamental right
it absolutely is and it must be
respected it's an important thing that
even in the intelligence community folks
are taught there's a an executive order
called twelve triple three the
three-letter agencies that we've talked
about actually are not permitted to
serve a u.s. persons without a direct
warrant and this is actually taught
trained inculcated it's a serious thing
so privacy matters you know even in in
places where people don't expect that it
matters but it especially matters to us
in this business I'm not affiliated with
the US government anymore it's not my
job but I am intent on doing private
transactions you will see Bitcoin like
transactions go away because they're not
private
they're their student honest sure enough
they're not private the very things that
I was telling you about anyone can look
in on the ledger and see what's moving
around means that's not a private
transaction through zero knowledge proof
there's a better way those transactions
can be off you skated such that only
those what they need to know will know
and the next part of that then is how do
you know who has a need to know we'll go
into that tier in a little bit but then
this what's really cool about the
blockchain that same immutable ledger
that allows you to see to verify that a
transaction took place also allows you
to verify who looked at this data so if
someone's looking at data for an
unauthorized region reason it becomes a
matter of the record because you can
actually protect that data on blockchain
itself so now you have a trace of every
time someone has done
thing looked at something that they
should ever shouldn't have seen and
under what authority they looked at it
that gives that should give a lot of
comfort to folks who now currently have
their data looked at by who knows whom
in in ways that they aren't aware of
yeah
so we believe in self sovereign identity
in in concept which allows you to
protect your own privacy data now what's
cool about the blockchain generally is
you can obfuscate so you can take and
tie behind the scenes a person's privacy
data from just a unique identifier and
even their that the unique identifiers
can be obfuscated it's important for
compliance reasons that that's tied to
an attribute so you spoke about the
great interview with Rong Chen you
pulled out your your ID and you say look
most people could just care had someone
verified that this is me then they're
you know as I show them my driver's
license they're getting a whole lot of
information I really don't need in fact
for most financial transactions like for
example I'm transacting in a reg d token
there's only a small number of
attributes that you need to know and
those attributes are not privacy
indicators so I'm a u.s. person that's
necessary in this transaction to know
that but there's a lot of us persons I'm
accredited investor there's lots of a
credit investors I'm not a principal in
the company in some company and you know
those things can be known without having
to give up the PII yeah so basically
there's privacy in the aggregation and
anonymization of your details right
basically I can I can describe you
without saying who you are and because
that description could be many many
people is really hard for me to pinpoint
that is you selling me an asset versus
somebody the only person the only thing
that a regulator or frankly anyone
engaged in a transaction really cares
about is this person illegitimate is
this a legitimate transaction and so
that's what needs to be known there's
there's ways you can you can verify
these things but there's a underneath
that is a really important role that
that we find to be central and we call
this a verification agent so if somebody
ky sees me doesn't know your customer
check on me how do I know that the
person who did that check is in fact
legitimate because you end up with a
race to the bottom problem if you anyone
can apply that attribute well the
financial system has rules for that
that's requires you to be a regulated
financial institution with a compliance
function to be able to verify a person
but there's other attributes that matter
for securities transactions and it's not
just a credit investor which is what
most of the security token offerings in
the space think that's all you really
need to know you need a lot more than
that but once you know those things and
they're verified by an entity who's
authorized to do so
you don't need anymore all other
compliance functions can happen
automatically in a decentralized way
that's radically different than the way
the financial system works today and so
it's once you get that foundation built
on identity and then layered on top of
that compliance you can do international
commerce in a way that is better than
the existing financial system that
completely gives the regulator's
assurance that only legitimate things
are happening at practically no cost
that revolutionizes all the finance
everything we know about finance and so
I guess as part of this before we go
talk about securin see one last guys for
the DIA NSA DHS etc one of the things
that I found fascinating some other
conversations is that some of these
government organizations were finding
ways to acquire Bitcoin for either
investigations research etc it was
pretty bureaucratic I think at that time
if you wouldn't understand what are we
buying you know are we basically just
lighting our money on fire or whatever
so there was mining and some of these
organizations etc during your time like
were you guys buying Bitcoin were you
using it to kind of send around and
analyze how money moved like like how
were you guys actually doing some of
this and not so much in a like academic
versus practical way put just more of
like when you when you step in in 2012
it's not like today where there's all
this information available or you can
just google around you can learn a lot I
think a lot of people were kind of hey
we had to learn by doing things right so
kind like what was that like oh yes oh
look I can't speak for all of government
to all of researchers particularly j'en
see we're a lot
things are going on what our particular
cut on this was just looking at the
blockchain itself so you don't even have
to have Bitcoin to do to analyze the
transactions that we're taking place on
Bitcoin but I mean it's may may or may
not be surprising there was a lot of say
seized Bitcoin of course takedown Silk
Road that's a lot of Bitcoin so the
government had a lot of Bitcoin and the
government I could probably say more
than you can there my understands
there's certain organizations that when
they seize Bitcoin they turn around they
auction it off and there's other
organizations that when they seize
Bitcoin they hold on to it and I'm sure
that can be used for a whole much
different things all right so you leave
when you leave dia what year 2015 2015
and kind of how did we go from 2015 to
the start of security I founded security
in 2015 it was really wasted no time I
don't know
so it was really on this on this concept
so we saw that you layer identity and
and then later we found out compliance
on top of blockchain you have the
perfect financial institution but the
other observation was there was a lack
of stable value in the space so I
couldn't invest my kids college
education in Bitcoin wish I had but you
know it's just not a reliable investment
thesis and so there needed to be a
reliable investment thesis and so we saw
the opportunity
it started with commercial real estate
income streams to bundle those streams
into dividend paying currencies there
was no such thing as a security token at
the time the concept had not been
developed but that's what that's what we
were looking at is these new kinds of
dividend paying instruments we cut we
saw that they would have the benefit of
a security and a currency and that's
where the name security came from okay
so we found it under that name and in
2015 and then we couldn't deny that
there were securities they were of
course they were securities that was the
name of our company was if there were
securities so we had to build out the
compliance layer to make it safe to
transact
in in these instruments so I thought
given how quickly we were able to
tokenize things like the income streams
I thought I'd take us about six months
to build out the compliance tools I was
off by about four years there's a lot of
work to really build the foundation to
be able to take securities regulations
from Singapore from the UK from the UAE
look since a security token can go
anywhere you have to respect all of
those laws to make it possible to build
a framework that could that was flexible
and where the laws could change and that
was not tied to a specific ledger that
took a while so we went about building
that somewhat quietly is we sense that
we were onto something that was a lot
bigger than what most folks saw in the
space it was also not a topic that no
one really cared about then man we
talked to VCS about compliance in the
blockchain space yes many of them were
just getting familiar with blockchain
generally but they certainly didn't see
any reason for compliance before 2017 so
we stayed very low-profile during that
time as we built out the the tools so
the other early observation that we made
is interoperability matters so we're
ledger agnostic and again that the
interview had with Ron Chen where he
basically said there can't be one ledger
there won't be one ledger if there's
ever one ledger it means the end of
innovation and so it's right to teach
treat Ledger's as something like a
database technology as a practical
matter just let's just say your wisdom
tree and you issue your your ETF fund on
aetherium the last thing you'd you'd
hate if ten years from now you're stuck
on a ledger which is no longer used
because it's outdated something betters
come along etc so from the very GetGo
you want to be ledger agnostic and so we
recognize the importance of that
approach and a built tools that actually
allows security tokens to move between
Ledger's the user can really decide
based on the characteristics they want
from a ledger where they wanted to go
got it and so what didn't you guys built
today Rea because I think you guys have
kind of obviously been at this a long
time built a whole bunch of different
things and you're taking kind of a
unique approach to how do you digitize
or tokenize assets most people are going
and finding illiquid assets that
you know currently aren't available in
liquid markets you guys are kind of
doing the opposite yeah yeah so the it's
good oscillation are the centerpiece of
all of our system starts with the
compliance we're token framework it's
not a protocol it's a framework where as
a first principle you do compliance that
framework it gets layered in two
different Ledger's so we're we can be
private permission Ledger's public
Ledger's we happen to believe strongly
that public Ledger's are the right way
to go but we're we don't really care you
lay the framework in and the compliance
tools follow and what that means is you
have a mechanism by which you can create
any token attach a set of a policy to it
and the token then knows what it's
allowed to do and while they allow
itself to engage in transactions between
known and qualified participants this
can be whether the value is a security
the value is a piece of data the rules
are very flexible they can be designed
and it's a special purpose language
around compliance the policies are
portable so you build it you show it to
the regulator regulator says no but that
matches my rules you test it and then
you use it over and over again as a
practical matter so that was the
starting point on this is you have to
have tokens that follow the rules and it
matters not just the rules in the US but
anywhere on top of that we've got an
interoperability framework and so what
our target always was institutional
investors so the thinking that you
tokenize a piece of real estate or a
piece of art that you're going to
suddenly get liquidity if you don't have
a liquid investment thesis you're not
going to have liquidity so in other
words if I can't if I can't know if that
piece of real estate is in good standing
without looking at it
there needs to be properly disclosures
associated with it and if I'm not in a
market if I know a walled garden you
know the natural access to a whole bunch
of investors is not going to be there so
you need to be outside a walled garden
that means the token should be able to
go anywhere as long as it follows the
rules and what you want is a liquid
investment thesis well what are the most
liquid instruments on the planet
exchange-traded funds so they have
strong pricing functions and so as we
interacted with WisdomTree the middle of
the year last year
they were seeing their industry
radically changing and so they
exchange-traded fund displaced and
disrupt the mutual fund they sense that
their industry is going to be
transformed by what comes next the
blockchain enabled fund and so they were
looking for solutions really to move
into this new space but they couldn't
compromise on compliance institutional
players can't so when we came together
we saw an opportunity to really solve a
big problem in the blockchain space got
it and so walk us through today you've
got wisdom trees now an investor you
guys have the ability to what's
fascinating to me as your digitizing or
tokenizing already liquid funds ETFs are
trading on the New York Stock Exchange
NASDAQ wherever you're actually
tokenizing those same ETFs and so now
there is a ability to go on a regulated
crypto exchange and buy a token just
like you can go on a regulated
traditional exchange in buy an ETF share
its same asset right it's just in two
different technology form factors why do
that right why create the tokenized
format is something that's already
liquid in a public market yeah perfect
so look the the fundamental benefits of
blockchain to the traditional ETF space
so just to be clear some folks are
working on creating exchange-traded
funds of crypto assets
so traditionally traded shares
non-traditional assets so the Bitcoin
Bitcoin ETFs where you're talking about
the Winklevoss twins bitwise Vanek all
these folks who have filed for I want an
ETF that allows somebody to buy a
traditional share and the New York Stock
Exchange or Nasdaq that gives them
access to Bitcoin yeah right exposure to
Bitcoin yep this is not that this is the
opposite of that
it's a token I share of a traditional
asset Treasury gold sp500 behind the
scenes so what's the advantage to them
their shares are already liquid why do
they need tokenization two fundamental
advantages first is the cost function so
blockchain allows for automation of the
back-office functions associated with
these assets there Industries already
under cost pressure to read you know as
the margins are going to
you can obliterate the COS structures
you can effectively automate all of fund
management through smart contracts so it
drives the cost of actually executing a
fund to zero that that benefits of
course investors within the space second
key benefits in the long run is greater
distribution actually in the short run
greater distribution so they produce a
fund it trades here in the US on let's
say the New York Stock Exchange they're
getting access to a large pool of US
investors at the retail and
institutional level it's kind a little
hard anyway to get access to those
exposures in Japan and Singapore etc
they'd like to be able to go big in all
markets at one time greater distribution
which will leads to greater size
portfolios so that you could a investor
in the UAE could get easy access and
exposure to US Treasuries US investors
could get easy exposure to European
Treasuries or to European stock exchange
etc you want that and that requires you
to have instruments traditional
financial instruments don't cross
borders easily tokens that know the
rules of all the borders actually can
and that's a new kind of market yeah and
I guess part of this is it's an access
play right to me the part that gets
misunderstood or isn't widely talked
about is there's a lot of people in the
world who can't buy an asset on the new
york stock exchange or on the Nasdaq and
to people here in the united states they
think that's a ridiculous idea but to
the people who don't have access because
they don't have a US bank account they
don't have a brokerage account right
they don't meet certain capital
requirements etc they don't have access
and therefore that ultimately leads to a
huge component of income inequality and
and exploitation so just as a example of
exactly that point so look just boiling
down fundamental benefits of blockchain
Consensus immutability is is central
the distributed Authority is central and
accessibility is central they all of
these things are critically important
like you said accessibility is really
important early on in our project 2016
we worked through MIT connections with a
company to do securitized loans in
developing world farm settings these
people don't have access to low-cost
capital the kind of exploitation that
occurs in in settings they were paying
butBut roughly 200 cent interest on
their loans in those in those settings
because they didn't have access to
capital in the way that we know it
there's terrible exploitation and
terrible stories of what happened to
those people before we were able to
introduce low-cost capital in those
settings it is a human tragedy frankly
that there isn't accessibility there it
also is an investor benefit so let's not
kid ourselves institutional investors
really benefit from having diverse
investment opportunities at global scale
so being able to get access to the
growth in real estate in Eastern Europe
is that's a great exposure to get when
Western economies slow down cetera they
don't currently have practical and
liquid access to those things and and so
through accessibility you can really
change that yeah and to me you start out
with the already accessible assets to
some portion of the population and just
expand that population percentage right
so let's say 70 percent of the world has
access to buying on the new york stock
exchange if you can expand that to a
hundred or ninety-nine or whatever the
number is that's actually much easier
than saying let's go find an asset that
only two percent have exposure to and
let's bring that 250 person yeah pump
look so this is a big big point right
now so the kinds of assets that are in
the security token space are generally
limited to accredited investors it's a
very small pool wisdom trees offerings
are publicly traded exchange-traded
funds you obliterate that small circle
folks who can actually enter the
blockchain space with these new kinds of
instruments they're not so limited so
you can we can access pools of folks and
give them high quality investment grade
instruments in
the blockchain space that folks didn't
previously have access to that's a big
story just by itself mm-hmm
and so give us an example of one of the
funds that you guys are doing this with
and we can kind of talk through how that
works yeah that's a piece for you to ask
WisdomTree
look so they wisdom trees gonna be quiet
right now okay yes that that's uh the if
you listen in on their interviews they
talk they have a number of marquee funds
right so among the most liquid gold
funds among the most liquid Treasury
funds you can get exposures to foreign
currency used etc these are great
starting points I have let me show you
this interesting problem all financial
transactions are really movement of
value between three dimensions liquidity
yield or return and stability so when I
take money out of the bank to get cash
that cash is depreciating I'm moving
from yield to convenience utility so
that that's a fourth dimension that's
that tokenization brings in which is
utility within the blockchain space the
volatility it's because you don't have a
stable asset to allow you to pivot
between those dimensions you haven't
been able to form efficient markets here
within the the security space there is
no such thing as utility I can't take my
shares of Apple and use them in
transactions I have to cash them in for
dollars and use them in this new world
you can so suddenly you're opening up a
new dimension for folks to move between
what does that mean the concept of a
traditional savings account where you
put your money at rest in a very low
yield instrument suddenly goes away when
you can put it into a higher yield
Treasury components or even more looking
at securitization or other yield or
return and then when you want to use it
you can convert it to cash to make
conduct a payment really instantaneously
so those things really transform the way
that securities behave yeah well what is
the biggest obstacle for you guys is it
on the compliance side or something else
it's probably institutional adoption
generally we've been friends with
regulators from the beginning friends is
not the right term we've been focused on
relationships with regulators from the
beginning one thing we haven't talked
about is we're overseas in we have a
fair-sized office in the UAE in Abu
Dhabi why we weren't there because that
we cared about liquidity that's a region
characterized by lack of liquidity they
had massive real estate funds massive
energy funds etc that need liquidity so
we decided that was the market for us to
attack to go into and we found that it
was heaven for us the the sovereigns
there recognized that they need they're
very interested in blockchain they need
to pivot their economies from oil based
economies to new tech models the the
regulators know that the sovereigns want
to get into this market in a big way so
they want to do it the right way so we
entered the market with compliance tools
and really got moved front of line so we
could work directly with the regulators
there so regulators hasn't been a
challenge for us we're working with them
we would go daily with regulators to
really work out the kinks so when we
first talked to the SEC it was pleasant
you know it's rare that you leave a
meeting and the regulator smiling and
you're smiling it was a these were good
constructive meetings we're actually
developing a pilot with regulators to
show how you can move value across
borders and respect various
jurisdictional regulations it's a really
institutional adoption and again
institutions have a lot to lose within
this space we are institution friendly
built for integration with institutions
but they just don't move aggressively
into the space balance-sheet matters in
finance is another key problem ballot
how much cash you have in the bank
determines how easy you can be sued and
how easy you can be sued determines how
safe you are for folks to to enter the
space startups by their nature
balance sheet mm-hmm so it's hard to get
into these big settings without a big
institutional partner but they're
frankly in their own way in many cases
we were fortunate enough to find
WisdomTree and they just had a brilliant
vision for the future and so now we've
got the best of both worlds for sure and
so as you think through working with
wisdom tree etc Adi after you go through
ETFs and kind of do that work what's the
next type of assets that you guys would
focus on yeah so again for all of these
things to work for things to be
convenient you need stability and so the
ETS had to be the starting point on this
but as you move out from there there's
really no limit in terms of core
functions when you can automate
compliance a lot of things fall so put
into place so whether it's just straight
payments remittances trade finance you
know again our core competencies in
securitization so that is taking then
and creating funds out of normally
illiquid things trade finance is a great
example of this lending generally
through blockchain you know D Phi's is a
real movement you can do self processing
loans and then you could pull those
loans and trade those driving down the
cost of Finance generally got it
before finished up I always do
rapid-fire questions what do you think
the most important company and crypto
other than your own is Microsoft why
that's not an answer I was expecting I
knew I could I'm so and actually let me
give a little shout out to Amazon as
well because they're really in the same
camp because here's here's the bottom
line
in finance it's all businesses are now
tech businesses in the end ok as they
boil down they boil down to
infrastructure plays we see Microsoft's
done great work in the infrastructure
the banking system the real threat to
them is the Amazon Microsoft's of the
world as a practical matter we've
recognized that and we build a layer on
top of their infrastructure services
which actually makes it effectively Bank
ready but that's where the play ends
in the end is those guys own the real
stuff and it's not I'm not just saying
that name because I recognize that
they're doing real things in this space
blockchain is just like just like Oracle
was relational databases were it is an
infrastructure technology absolutely and
so that they no one can do it better
than those two guys at scale
I got a Gregory I got a great FedEx
story for you earlier this week some tax
was due on January 15th for lots of
Americans and decided go mail mine in
and there's a FedEx store on the corner
and so I walk in and I had basically I
had a couple of different envelopes that
I had to send I had one envelope but I
needed two others and so the guy that
FedEx I said you have envelopes he goes
we do I said all right can you help me
mail this and he looks at the first
envelope I'd already thought I was oh we
can't send anything to peel boxes so
what I never thought of well it's a
post-office box right he goes yeah we're
not allowed to do that I said okay
that's fine I said well can I get the
envelopes for you and then I'll go over
to the post office across the street he
goes well here's the problem is if you'd
get a FedEx envelope they won't take it
at the post office and I'm sitting there
just like in what world does the side
load systems not work right and this is
coming from who I don't mail things all
the time right so I just figured it was
like technologies like everything's
interoperable but even the mail system
between a private company and kind of
the public post office completely siloed
and and doesn't kind of coexist which
was a or they coexist but doesn't
interoperate and which was pretty
surprising how much worse is the
financial sector though in the Bible
we're just fragmented yeah right at
least that you can use your ATM your ATM
card at other people's ATMs right which
is a great yeah all right so what uh
what do you if you could choose any
regulation to change or law what would
you change or improve yeah so look you
know the first going in position is loss
are actually pretty good so there's you
know thinking in the blockchain spaces
these are antiquated they're actually
there for a reason and they've stood the
test of time
however the accredited investor
rule as it stands can be changed it is
very important it always will be
important for securities regulators to
protect the public from people who would
prey on the ICO debacle is really an
example of this however it shouldn't be
based on net wealth only the reason for
the law was in the 1930s after the crash
people from New York City went and
started preying on people's pension
funds in the Midwest and were taking
their life savings what really matters
is how much of your life savings you're
putting at risk so if I go and put two
thousand or four thousand dollars in an
investment it shouldn't really matter if
I'm putting a hundred thousand dollars
in an investment then it should matter
you know whether I'm calling psych a
percentage of your net worth
type requirement yeah so look the UK has
lost some or this it's really below a
certain threshold you can do whatever
you want it as long as you don't exceed
that threshold that's in the reason that
why that's so important for the national
economy right and chairman Clayton
recognizes this is more and more things
are leaving the public markets into the
private markets and so the that what
that means is the rich are getting
richer because they're the only ones who
have access to these investment
opportunities so the SEC knows it needs
to change change will happen I think
yeah I agree
most important book you've ever read the
Bible is is I'm shocked it's the more
popular answer yeah I think a lot of
people think it and they're scared to
say it yeah look so you know there's
good principles to live by there what I
found is when I when I follow those
rules of do unto others as you would
have them do unto you it leaves the
peace and peace with my wife these with
my kids
peace with the people around me so yeah
I'm about to get married I'm learning
quickly
Wayne is probably listening to this and
she said I want to screw his day of he
[ __ ] around aliens believe him not
believe them real not real seen one
before
and this seen one before no no it's so
better not be real here's here's why I
don't know if you've ever seen the
there's a great piece came out in 1998
from MIT called the great filter
I have not no definitely check it out
here's the basic theory and I think this
is pretty much an axiom that if if we've
not seen direct evidence of
extraterrestrial life right now I think
we can all agree that that's true not
repeatable evidence and we should have
based on on this life propagates it does
so aggressively we've already seen in a
short period of time since the beginning
of flight that we've left our solar
system so we're able to move out and in
1940 a guy his name is von Neumann
posited something called a von Neumann
probe it's basically this it's it's sort
of the same thing that that bacteria
does in terms of the way it goes out
built a probe that goes and replicates
and builds and other probe and goes and
you can propagate then effectively at
the speed of transmission which will
become something close to the speed of
light the Milky Way is about 13 billion
years old earth is about four billion
years old in a hundred years we've seen
this kind of movement so there is a
great the fact that we've not
encountered another civilization in a
thousand years we will probably have
moved to other planets and from there be
moving and von Neumann almost at the
point of life let's speed of light
across the thousand years I think that
we will be on at least one other planet
if not more than 100 soon as you get on
to one yeah there's three dis effect you
will go everywhere and again it's we
already know how to do it at a speed
that's dramatic so there's an important
question that's raised by the great
filter is if if that's true for sentient
life if you're capable of moving that
fast and we have every reason to believe
that you are one of two things happens
this must be true one is getting to
sentient life must be so hard that
there's a filter prior to this and they
pause at a number of different points
that actually is harder than we think
for it to occur in the process of
evolution or sentient life destroys
itself before it propagates I think we
have some evidence
that we can do that to ourselves and so
as a matter of principle
something about sentient life causes it
to be self-destructive and so one of
those two things are true so if in fact
there are aliens at some level on this
what that means is what lies ahead for
us based on the probabilities is that
we're going to destroy ourselves read
the paper it's so profoundly important
MIT 1998 the great filter the great
filter you can you can I'm gonna
literally read it later today I you're
touching on a point of whether if aliens
exist do we actually want them to
discover us or do we want to make sure
that we discover them right and the
whole idea is anytime that humans have
invaded other human populations usually
turns out much better for the people
invading than the people being invaded
and so if you think of that in terms of
humans vs. aliens it's unlikely that we
want to be discovered and is much more
likely that we want to do the discovery
well look so again life propagates so at
all forms in every form it grows into
its environment and so it's it might be
true that that's not always true but we
have every reason everything that we've
ever seen shows that that's true one or
the other in the event that we encounter
someone else is going to propagate it's
crazy
what question you have for me to finish
up before I go crawl in the corner and
feel like I am the smallest thing in the
universe dang so what would you tell a
16 year old you 16 year old what what
lesson would you pass on and say hey
don't do this
it wouldn't be not to do things uh it
would be a couple of minutes she's not
having you just one thing I think that
over time I've learned certain things
that at sixteen would be much more
valuable the first being like swing for
bigger opportunities right when I fell
sorry before but when I moved to Silicon
Valley I was in fourteen went met with
the only guy that I knew
lived out there Scot Ben Smith was
running a company called wonderful media
and asked what's the best advice you
have for me he said there's two things
one keep it personal burn rate as low as
possible because it'll allow you to take
on opportunities that if you have a high
burnt you know personal expense rate you
just can't do right so you have to take
a job that a lot but could be a big
opportunity
second is you'll be much more rewarded
for taking big opportunities and failing
then you will be for having small
success and I think that you know
another data point on that Steve
Schwarzman in his recent book whatever
it takes he talks about it's just as
hard to do the big thing as it is the
small things you might as well go do the
big thing so I think that's kind of a
reoccurring theme the second is I over
time realized but did not when I was 16
years old like you become the five
people you hang out with and so I you
know pickle I have had very very great
friends along the way
but I think that as you start to
understand you can have friends and then
you can have people that are those five
people you spend the most time with you
kind of just level up a little bit I
think that's helpful and the third thing
is there's a weird thing that I think
you can't tell a 16 year old because 16
year old won't believe it but it's just
do you like just be happy who the [ __ ]
cares what anybody else says or does no
Tom and I forget the quote and who says
it but it's something like you know you
spend your 20s like thinking everyone is
talking about you you spend your 30s 40s
50s whatever it is and then it's like
and they spend your 60s realizing no
one's ever paying attention right like
whatever that quote is it just always
sticks in my head is just like no
literally nobody [ __ ] cares and the
people who think that they care are
actually probably just jealous this was
actually a trick question cuz I got
teenagers saying great you just you took
my job good job is how father what do
you tell them make their bed get the bed
on time don't play video games so not
well nearly is you okay so we only got a
minute or two here but one of the
questions I have for you is how do you
how do you handle them now saying but I
could be a multi-millionaire
professional athlete playing video games
does that be the first thing I would say
my father Tony same thing stop playing
the [ __ ] video games go outside you
know really do all the things that a
parent would say
there was nobody that we could point to
be like well that guy's a multi million
you know dollar professional eSports
player but now there's a number yeah
yeah so it's the danger because every
one of them thinks they can be of course
and it's the same thing as well I can't
they be a multi-million dollar
quarterback in the NFL because it's
there are only a couple people who can
do that yep so you know that's the
bottom line
on it and other than that it's a lark
you got to recognize that that competes
with your ability to be productive in
other areas and it's everything's
work-life balance in in all of this but
if you can't keep it at work-life
balance and because you have this dream
it's dangerous
yeah the the one thing you said make
your bed the other thing that I I think
a lot about is every person that has
attained some level of quote-unquote
success that I've talked with and I
asked them what was the secret majority
of them will say some version of
persistence like showing up every day
etc and the whole making your bed is a
perfect example of just like there's
things that you got to do every day
right and if you can learn that habit
it's pretty powerful in every and I
learned this way too late discipline in
every aspect of what you do you know
that daily commitment to doing the right
thing is is this you will never go far
if you do that from success you'll
always be moving on I think it is wind
on this but I think it's Jaco will Nick
who says a discipline equals freedom
right people think that the discipline
is a bad thing but actually they realize
once you have the discipline you're able
to accomplish things when you accomplish
things it equals freedom so transitive
property which I tend to use as an
excuse all time alright listen thank you
so much for doing this I really
appreciate it and what dude again thanks
mom